the first thing I'll start with is I
love how many characters in this movie
process things via books TV shows and
movies so for you two individually what
is the the movie The Book or show that
you refer to most and helps you like
process this crazy world
there were uh
there were there were total that's kind
of multiple buckets it's hard to pick
one there was like narrative
inspirate like
we were writing it like they live in The
Truman Show like we're like had a baby
you know
um I've been like tonally you know we
were looking at like Big Lebowski and
Boogie Nights and you know Jackie Brown
uh so those are definitely like uh you
know movies that like
kind of combine to like you know
influence us like we were like sitting
down like crafting it and like in the
world building I actually like movies
like The World building thing like it
follows like Napoleon Dynamite it's just
in the sense of like the
like the anachronisms in the world
building and like that kind of temporal
dissonance where you're kind of not
exactly like you know the question kind
of comes up of is this a period like no
it's not right like you know but it
feels like it wait you know I think a
lot of that you know we were inspired by
you know Napoleon Dynamite and it
follows you are name dropping all the
right things
I love it all of those what about like
day to day you too walking down the
street what's the movie or the show or
the book that weighs most heavily on
your mind oh day to day okay my final
destination I think everything is going
to be a new Final Destination
all right so there's a book called why
should white guys have all the fun I
think about that every day in the
business that I'm building uh in life
the themes of Braveheart you know just
like that that that that sits and then
uh I don't know there's a show Ali law I
referenced that quite a bit in terms of
a character on his show that inspired me
you know I was a Blair Underwood
character those are three things I touch
on quite a bit I like those I like those
no Final Destination fans here
I know I mean I think
the way you took it I was like oh yeah
because I was gonna say like so I'm like
Back to the Future but I guess I don't
think about that while I'm walking
around
but like you know I feel like I'm like
you know more awesome like Dragon Ball Z
that sounds like my hero or you know
something like that I'm Shonen I'd
probably walk around with a shown in
mind you know
I like all these examples here so you
brought up your company and a little bit
of a broader question with that because
like yet again this industry is going
through a seismic shift in terms of how
we're making movies and how we're
Distributing them so what are some of
your changing goals and approaches to
make sure that you are always seeing
your original mission statement with
macro throw
um changing goals and approaches look
with the chaos of what's happening
through our industry and and I think
this they're finding opportunity and
there's always going to be opportunity
for a really uniquely positioned great
new voices and
um and we just want to be a part of that
and continue to find the the right
platforms for great voices to be out in
the marketplace and honestly the other
thing is
commercial projects as well for us in
terms of we've been involved with a lot
of critically acclaimed projects and I
think a film like this I believe this
widely commercial but also like the
quality of the filmmaking and
storytelling definitely hopefully could
Garner conversations as well oh without
a doubt Garner conversations with with
themes and also with the details and I
have a feeling those details are going
to keep people coming back from multiple
viewings and it's making me think of
something I read in the I think it's our
production notes you had said this all
started with I think a tone and a Vibe
and what I see in the end is like this
wild genre bending mashup with so many
World building details so what would you
say is the biggest difference between
how you originally envisioned this all
playing out day one when you first came
up with a concept and what we now see in
the finished feature
yeah
honestly like
I gotta bring it back to cast you know
uh
nothing ever like comes out the way you
imagined it in your head and you just
hope that like if it's different and
it's gonna be different but like you
know hopefully you know when I was at
film school I felt like like oh that
ain't quite what else I would make
something film school and be like
hmm
it's not exactly what I said you know
what I mean it's always that um
you know but
because they brought the characters to
life and like it's the biggest
difference is really like it's just so
hard to imagine like truly what it would
look like when you're in a room and like
Jamie Foxx is inhabiting the character
and Tiano and and John is inhabiting the
character and like even you know the The
Supporting Cast or like keep for
suppering and David Alan Greer and it's
like
it's like impossible to like
imagine what that's gonna feel like
tonally like like
seeing those characters come to life
with like such a
crazy amount of talent like you like
you know what I mean it's like you write
a character on the page and he's stoic
and then John is warm like it's got this
dry humor and it's like ha you know like
there was a as a a template of this
character that you that you had you know
years and years and years ago that you
lived with for years you know before you
know we the idea before we they were cat
if it was a movie it was just an idea
that was on the page and it spent many
years like gestating before a actor
inhabited it and so you know you it's
come it's become Concrete in your mind
and baked into your mind like what they
look like what they sound like how they
move their personality and then like the
actors completely like bring them to
life and it's always like better than
what you imagine it would be of course
you know with Talent like that and it's
not always better than what you imagine
to be going back to film school going
off in your life you know and that ain't
the actress file that's usually my fault
you know I'm like oh I could have did a
better job with that or you know but
like in this case you know when you have
talent at like that level it's like I
would imagine it's you know always
better than you than you saw it being
inside I would say that's the biggest
difference to get a little specific with
that idea can you tell me one thing in
the movie whether it's I don't know
something in the production design
something an actor delivers that I like
had more potential than you ever
realized when you finished the script
where it just left left off the screen
in a way you never thought it was
capable of all kind of stuff especially
go to production design shout out to
Franco yeah
um like just seeing how the world was
brought to brought to the screen you
know when you I mean again like we first
set out to make it the scale was like we
imagined a much smaller scale you know
like we we had no idea that these actors
would say yes you know what I'm saying
and like with these actors broad scale
right like uh and so you're seeing the
world build in a way that like you know
you see goddamn fried chicken and it's
like when you walk in the cell you're
like oh wow you know I'm saying like oh
okay what's up Franco you know when you
see I mean from a performance day you
see the elevator scene and it's like
it's a couple of lines of Pros maybe
like two eighths of a page
just the song but then they turn it into
a performance here like
I'll let you know man and like just
seeing like how the three of them played
off of each other again it's like
way better it turned out way better than
you know it could have been cut easily
you know but then all of a sudden the
actors like bring it to life and it's
like okay
this this isn't as stupid as I thought
it was uh on the page you know like it's
just it's the actors man they they make
it they make it way better than it has
any right to be give yourself some
credit too there's a lot going on here
and unless you have that conductor who's
able to bring all that exceptional work
together this idea does not work and you
crush it thank you for your time tonight
congratulations thank you